[Music]
i am
an invisible man mrs dalloway said she
would buy the flowers
herself you are about to begin reading
italo calvino's new novel
these three opening lines from ralph
ellison's invisible
man virginia woolf's mrs dalloway and
italo calvino's
if on a winter's night a traveler each
establish a different
point of view who is telling a story and
from what perspective
are some of the most important choices
an author makes
told from a different point of view a
story can transform completely
take this fairy tale rapunzel rapunzel
the prince called let down your hair
rapunzel unbraided her hair and slung it
out the window
the prince climbed her tresses into the
tower
rapunzel is typically told like this
with the narrator outside the story
this point of view is called third
person but rapunzel can also be told by
a character in the story
a first person narrator the tail end of
rapunzel's locks plopped down at my feet
i grabbed on and began to climb ugh
i couldn't untangle myself strands came
off all over me
sticking to my sweat in a first person
narrative
the story can change dramatically
depending on which character
is the narrator say rapunzel was
narrating instead of the prince
i hope he appreciates how long it takes
to unbraid
25 feet of hair i thought
i'll be honest i thought my scalp would
stretch off my skull
can you climb any faster i yelled
in second person the narrator addresses
the story
to the reader he calls your name
he wants you to let your hair down you
just finished braiding it
but hey you don't get a lot of visitors
third person
first person and second person
perspectives each have unique
possibilities
and constraints so how do you choose a
point of view for your story
constraints aren't necessarily a bad
thing they can help
focus a story or highlight certain
elements
for example a third person narrator is
necessarily
a bit removed from the characters but
that can be good for stories where a
feeling of distance
is important a third-person narrator can
be either limited
meaning they stick close to one
character's thoughts and feelings
or they can be omniscient able to flit
between characters minds and give the
reader more information
a first person story creates closeness
between the reader
and the narrator it's also restricted by
the narrator's knowledge
this can create suspense as the reader
finds out information along with the
character
a first-person narrator doesn't
necessarily have to represent the
character's experience
faithfully they can be delusional or
dishonest
in kazuo ishiguro's novel the remains of
the day
stephens an aging british butler in 1956
recounts his many years of service but
fails to acknowledge the flaws of the
man he
serves the cracks in his narrative
eventually draw the reader's attention
to the under acknowledged
failings of the culture and class system
he inhabits
justin torres novel we the animals
begins with a plural first person
narrator
we were six snatching hands six stomping
feet
we were brothers boys three little kings
locked in a feud for more
part way through the story the point of
view shifts to first person singular
from we to i as the boys come of age and
one brother feels alienated from the
others
second person is a less common choice it
requires
the writer to make the reader suspend
disbelief to become
another you placing the reader in a
character's perspective
can build urgency and suspense sometimes
though
second person is intended to distance
the narrator from their own
story rather than bring the reader
closer to the story
in these cases second person narrators
refer to themselves as
you rather than i writers are
constantly experimenting with fresh
variations on point of view
new virtual and augmented reality
technologies
may expand the possibilities for this
experimentation
by placing people at a particular
vantage point in virtual space
how might we change the way we tell and
experience stories
interested in tips on making your own
writing more captivating
learn how to inject suspense into your
stories with this video
or how to heighten your humor with this
[Music]
video